Now, Javascript at first glance really doesn't resemble the same sort of object
oriented programming languages that you see in C and C++ code.
Now these are typically the languages that games are written in, NES, Super NES,
XBox 360, PS3, all had some resemblance of this. Now Javascript provides a way
that you can define a set of variables as well as functions encapsulated as an
object called a prototype. But for game dev, we're really missing the
inheritance factor, that is the ability to define that prototype and have
another one inherent from it. Luckily, we can duct tape JavaScript just enough
to make it look like we're getting classes and structure definitions. Now this
type of setup is actually the backbone of how everything works inside of grids.
So, before we move on, make sure that you're very, very familiar with this type of programming model.